♪ ♪ ♪
- Mélissa Bédard, vous êtes
entrée dans le coeur des
Québécois il y a 10 ans avec
la finale de Star Académie.
Ça va faire 10 ans.
En rétrospective, cette
aventure-là, est-ce que cititit
comme gagner à la loterie?
- Oh mon Dieu, c'était comme...
c'était comme... c'était
vraiment un rêve de jeunesse,
là, tu sais, parce que moi
j'ai écouté toutes les éditions
Star Académie. Mon père, ça me
rappelle encore ce que je
disais : Eille, moi, un jour,
je vais faire Star Académie.
Il était comme : "Bien oui,
bien oui, fille, c'est ça."
é é écoute, c'est le début,
c'était mon école.
Moi, j'ai pas suivi de
cours  de chant ou autre.
J'ai rencontré plein de
personnalités, j'ai vraiment
appris l'assiduité à
Star Académie. Pour moi,
c'était mon école, c'était
vraiment une école.♪ Donne-moi ♪
- Votre histoire, on la connaît.
Vous êtes née en Haïti,
vous êtes arrivée au Québec
un an plus tard grosso modo.
Et puis, c'est un peu le décès
de votre mère adoptive,
vous aviez 10 ans, qui vous
a vraiment poussée à faire
de la musique. Est-ce que
pour vous la musique c'est
un symbole de résilience?
- Bien en tout cas p p plus tôt
que je me souviens, moi,
je voulais être une danseuse
derrière Britney Spears.
- OK...
- Donc là, on a... encore là,
il y avae e e la musique,
mais c'était pas...
c'était pas concret, là,
que j'avais une voix.
Mes parents, ma famille
me disent que je chantais
tout le temps, mais pour moi,
c'est vraiment venu après
le décès... et même encore
plus loin au secondaire,
avec la chorale de l'école
que là je me suis dit : OK,
j'ai peut-être quelque chose.
Les professeurs m'ont entendue,
puis ils m'ont dit : "Ouais,
elle a une voix, tu pourrais
faire quelque chose de positif
avec ça." Puis, c'est comme ça
que ç'a commencé
♪ Alléluia ♪
♪ Allélu... ♪
- Ça fait tellement longtemps
que je voulais vous rencererer,
parce que tout le monde me dit :
"Ah! tu vas voir Mélissa Bédard,
extraordinaire, toujours de
bonne humeur, toujours gentille,
super généreuse". Il vient
d'où ce rayo s s soleil-là?
Pourquoi vous êtes comme ça?
- Ah bien ça, c'est une bonne
titition, puis je sais y
répondre. C'est que je sais...
en tout cas, j'ai été adopté,
fait que je le sais, que
j'aurais pu ne pas avoir
tout ça. Je pense vraiment
que ça vient du fait que
je me remets toujours en tête.
Je suis une fille très terre
à terre qui se rappelle que :
OK, t'aurais pu être en Haïti
dans la misère, mais non,
t'as été adoptée, on t'a donné
une voix en plus de ça
qui permet que tu peux aider
les autres, peut-être mettre
en lumière d'autre monde
avec d'autres projets.
C'est ce qui me pousse
à choisir des ptststs
aussi qui font du bien,
qui aident les gens,
le partage, tout ça.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Mélissa Bédard, vous êtes
mère de trois filles,
belle-mère de trois garçons,
on peut vous voir dans
l'émission "Ma première maison".
- Oui.
- Comment faites-vous la
conciliation travail-famille?
Une artiste, c'est un travail
à temps plein déjà.
- Vraiment, c'est vraiment à
temps plein, puis encore là,
dans les malheurs là, tu sais,
avec la COVID qui était
négative, on aé é é du beau.
Karl, mon mari, est devenu
papa à la maison,
fait que ça fait en sorte
que je peux faire les contra
que je veux, dire oui plus
souvent sans me casser la tête,
sans m'inquiéter de mes enfants.
Je sais qu'ils sont en train
de bonnes mains avec papa,
puis pour eux autr
c'est moins déstabilisant
aussi que de voir toujours
les deux parents partir
le matin travailler, puis maman
elle ne revient pas le soir.
Je suis beau!
- Je suis beau.
- Je m'aime!
- Je m'aime.
- Je veux parler de
grossophobie, parce que vous
avez abordé ce thème-là vraiment
sensible dans la belle série
"J't'aime gros",
série essentielle qui a
beaucoup animé... oui,
avec Christine Morency.
À l'ère des réseaux sociaux...
- Oui.
-... ça peut devenir compliquer
parce que là, il y a même
des gens qui vous espionnent
et qui surveillent
votre poids en ligne.
(rire)
Non, mais c'est vrai!
- Oh mon Dieu! Ah oui, ça,
ç'a fait toute une saga, ça,
pour un beau veston, puis un
beau pantalon finalement.
- Oui!
- On l'a vendu beaucoup plus
ce veston-là, mais que...
- Mais comment vous vivez ça?
- C'est que je me suis rendue
compte que peu importe là
qu'on soit gros, qu'on soit
mince, qu'on soit...
peu importe la différence,
on va toujours se comp,,,
fait que je me donne comme
mission d'en parler, d'en
montrer. Moi, c'est pas rare
qu'on va me voir dans le centre
d'achat pas maquiller là,
avec la perruqn n n peu croche.
C'est moi dans la vie.
- Fabi!
lllô mon amour!
- Fabiola, dans "M'entends-tu?",
quelle série extraordinaire.
Il y a eu trois saisons de ça.
Comment ça a changé aussi
votre carrière, celelele-là?
Parce que là, on a vu la
Mélissa Bédard interprète,
mais là vraiment comédienne?
mmmmmment on devient comédienne
du jour au lendemain?
- C'est un... moi, je dis
toujours qu'il y a un avant
et un après "M'entends-tu?".
Je suis tombée en amour
avec la Fabiolarararce que
j'avais l'impression que
la Mélissa de Star Ac', c'est
la Mélissa un peu plus parfaite.
T'sais, elle veut pas dépasser
ses barres, elle veut bien
faire pour arriver à devenir
quelqu'un dans le moule.
Fabiola me permettait
de retrouver la Mélissa,
jeune maman d'un enfant
qui l'a pas eu facile,
qui a "rushé" pour y arriver.
Ç'a fait sortir mon naturel,
tout simplement. Puis ça...
remettre un masque puis
faire semblant que ma vie
a toujours été parfaite.
Puis d'un autre côté,
ma vie imparfaite fait en sorte
que... ma vie imparfaite,
qui est maintenant pas parfaite,
mais qui est maintenant bien,
va inspirer d'autres gens
qui ont une vie, pour eux
à leurs yeux, pas parfaite
à devenir plus.
- Mélissa Bédard, quelle
entrevue. Merci beaucoup.
- Merci.
♪ ♪